neural networks
uh hi everyone i'm adity it's a great
pleasure to be here
i work broadly on robust and reliable
deep learning and today i'll talk about
some of the failure modes that happen in
neural networks and you know what we can
do about it given that they don't really
learn causal mechanisms and hence
they're like you know they can get
affected by serious correlations
okay so as many of y'all are probably
aware uh neural networks are the
workhorses that have powered some of the
most impressive advances that we've been
seeing in ai for example like alphago
and gpt3 and so on
every once in a while purely for my
entertainment i open gpt3 and i you know
try to see what it does in certain
things
and so this time i asked to like explain
to a 10 year old the first line of this
workshop and they actually did a pretty
reasonable job like it you know explain
something about causality like what tcs
is about and how we want to bring
everyone together
uh to make things that are more robust
or less likely to give incorrect results
so well this is why not far like the
most impressive application or anything
but you know this is just for fun
but we see that you know neural networks
have actually enabled pretty um
impressive advances and so a lot of
people are excited about using deep
networks to solve many problems
so the usual pipeline to do so is to
collect some training data like a lot of
training data
and then you pick some kind of the
latest and greatest model architecture
then you put them together and you like
you know have some objective to fit this
training data
and then you get your final model
parameters
okay so like the obvious issue here is
that your training data could contain a
lot of correlation some of which are you
know useful some of which are not useful
or meaningless
and these are going to show up in your
model
and this turns out to be a real problem
and and i think it's one of the biggest
challenges that we have in like using
these highly predictive models in
practice is that you don't know how to
evaluate these models because they do
fit your training distribution well but
like when you actually deploy them
things can get things can break because
you're deploying them in new
environments or new populations where
some correlations don't hold up
so as an example um
this is an image of a chest x-ray and
let's say we're trying to use machine
learning to help us determine whether it
has a collapsed lung or not
and you can do the usual collector
training data set and train a model and
you know people did this and it turns
out you can do quite well for example on
the health our test said the accuracy is
pretty high
and it correctly classified that this
image here is a collapse long
but upon further examination was found
that actually why the model made this
prediction was because of using this
treatment which is this tube uh on the
x-ray here
and so in the data set when you
collected like all the patients who are
identified to have the collapsed lung
also received treatment and so there was
a spurious correlation and so when
people actually tried to deploy this
model it didn't really do anything at
all because it cannot detect untreated
collapsed lungs
so here's like one example of how
certain correlations in a data set you
know seem to be useful for making
predictions but you don't really want
your model to use them because they
don't you know they're not going to work
when you use them
so there are many other such examples
like you know once i mean they can be
pretty catastrophic as well like a
self-driving car ended up killing a
woman because among other issues
it was only trained to recognize
pedestrians at crosswalks and so when
there was a pedestrian was jaywalking
the model didn't know you had to stop
because it assumed that you were only
stopping for the crosswalk and not the
notion of a pedestrian
okay
so that way i view it like i think
the fact that you have these neural
networks that
they're just giant models that can pick
a lot of complex patterns from the data
set you don't have to hand engineer
features and that was kind of like the
main selling point and why everyone's
excited about it because you don't have
to sit down and come up with good
features and the models are picking up
something
but like it's a double-edged sword
because sometimes like you have no idea
what the model is picking up you can't
control these and so this can be pretty
challenging when you want to
say that certain predictive features are
what you actually want the model to use
and you don't want it to pick anything
and everything that it finds in the data
set
so in this talk i'll kind of talk a
little bit about how we can try to
enforce some structure in what these
neural networks do end up learning we're
looking at a very simple starting case
where you know certain attributes in
your data set they're correlated but you
just don't want your model to pick that
up how do you actually train a network
to obey that constraint
then i'll go a little bit like and i'll
use that as the starting point to talk
more broadly about like where we think
the research and neural networks is
going to go and how do we bridge this
gap between them not learning causal
structures but still want to retain
their predictive power
with that i'll jump into the first part
which is on removing unknown spurious
correlations from the dataset
so first i'll discuss the setup and
evaluation and then i'll you know try to
cover the story about how we can fix
some of these issues
okay so just to recap models do latch
onto spurious correlations like we saw
in the chest x-ray where these are
misleading heuristics and so you know if
for example if it held up on all of your
training examples maybe that's
impossible to disambiguate at all so
let's assume that they don't always work
so there are some points in the data set
that it doesn't work but like how does
the model actually perform in such a
situation
here's a simpler example with no fewer
medical terms so this is an image of a
bird and let's say we're trying to train
a model to decide whether it is a water
bird or a land bird
and as you've probably guessed there is
a spurious correlation in the background
because most water birds occurred in
water and land birds in land
and if you look at the average error it
looks pretty good like three percent if
you like use a good neural network
but the model is actually using the
background to make its predictions so if
you have an image like this where the
bird is actually a water bird and the
true label is water
things are fine
but if you have an example
um
yeah so things are right in this
situation where the background is
actually matching the label even if the
model used the background to make its
predictions things are fine
but if you have an image like this which
is a land
sorry a water bird in a land background
the model is going to use its background
to make its prediction so even though
this is a dark it's going to say that
this is land because it's detecting the
background
and so in such examples the model makes
a mistake
and it's not just as one example like on
you know aggregated over the entire data
set the model gets 40 percent error on
such examples of water birds and land
background because it's predominantly
using the background to make its
predictions
so here is a setting where like you know
we know that background is a spurious
correlation and there is a lot more
signal in the foreground that the model
should be picking up on and so we're
trying to look at how do we get a model
to actually do that
so the way we set this up is that let's
assume it's binary classification for
simplicity and that there are two kinds
of backgrounds so your spurious
attribute can take one of two values and
your label can take one of two values
so we can construct our two by two grid
depending on the attribute and the label
for each of the data points
so most of your data points have the
background matching the label like water
births found in water background
and
this is an example
but there are some minority points where
sometimes you do have these situations
where there is a burden a different
background and so those are the minority
points
so in this way we can put each you know
each input into one of these four
categories and for now we're assuming
that for each input we can't say what
the background is and what the label is
and so we can put them into these four
categories
so now we can look at what is the error
of a model that is just trained on a
data set with this kind of a
distribution and how what does it do
so it gets pretty good performance on
the majority group so it gets like five
percent and point four percent but you
can see that it has very high error on
the minority groups
so the average error is pretty good
and but the error on the minority groups
is really high because the model is
using the background to make its
predictions and so it gets things wrong
where the background doesn't actually
match the label
so viewed in this way like this is
convenient because now this tells us
that like what we want if we want to say
that the model does not use a spurious
attribute
is that we want to train models which
have small errors on all these different
groups
so if you have a model that gets you
know good performance on birds
irrespective of their backgrounds then
that says that the model is actually not
using the background
so this is like so we set this up this
problem of like removing spurious
correlations from the data set as one in
which you have different groups in your
population and you want your model to
like work well even on like groups which
are the minorities
um yeah
we know uh which group
uh
the photo falls into yeah so in this
situation we're assuming that we like we
can look at uh so this is actually uh
this this particular data set is
synthetically constructed so you do have
that attribute of the background the
foreground and some other datasets that
we've done these experiments on we have
the meta information on like what the
attributes are
well like if i have time in like the
later part i'll talk about what we could
potentially do if you don't have that
information
are there any other questions so far on
the setup and evaluation
okay
so now you know viewed that way we want
to improve the voice group error
and the natural strategy is you know you
have a data set which there are
different groups and so some groups are
minority your model is going badly there
is some imbalance and so the natural
technique is to rewrite the laws based
on different group proportion
so what this means is that there are a
lot more examples on the majority so
what we'll do is we will reduce the
weights on those points in the loss and
we increase the weight on the minority
points
so this is an attempt to get the model
to really pay attention to these
minority groups and not just ignore them
uh or like because they're just a few of
them don't get a high loss on them like
really try to get it right
so this is the natural like you know
objective that we could try which is to
increase the weight on the groups which
are small in size
you could do some slightly yeah sorry
i
can't see the slides anymore
was it something did i do something okay
let me know if that happens again
um
okay so
yeah so this is kind of the natural
strategy but you could do something more
sophisticated as well which is like you
know maxima like do some robust
optimization which is to minimize the
worst case error on your training data
set because that's kind of the objective
you're measuring on the test set as well
and as i'll show in the next slide we'll
look at how these uh methods work and uh
these like robust optimization problems
pretty similarly to increasing the
weight so i'll just focus on this up
waiting approach because it's more
intuitive
okay so
so with that studying we can look at
what happens when we actually try to
train these models with this
re-weighting
so the same bird example from before
um so this is the visualization of the
performance as you increase the size of
the models so the parameter account is
basically the size of the models
so i'll walk through all these lines so
first let's observe the test error which
is like the average test error so we're
not accounting for any like group
information we're just looking at the
average performance on the test set
so we see that as we increase the size
of the models the test error goes down
and actually you get pretty good test
error for large models and so for people
who are familiar with deep learning it
kind of confirms the trend that we are
familiar with where if you use larger
models the performance is better and
right now we have a lot of you know push
towards using like you know trillions of
parameters or something so it kind of
matches like the common wisdom here
but if you look at the voice group error
we find something interesting which is
that the error first goes down and then
kind of goes up again
and so if you look at the largest model
it actually obtains a pretty high voice
group error compared to the smaller
models that like are somewhere in
between
so this is pretty surprising because
this is quite like we never see such
grass typically in machine learning if
you look at the literature because all
the graphs look like the you know the
black graph here and it's called the
double descent phenomenon where like you
know you're having larger models
actually just works better and you don't
have an overfitting problem
so if you look at the voice group error
you are seeing that like well actually
overfitting is a problem and using
smaller models is better
so just to make sure this is not an
artifact of this data set we can look at
other data sets as well and uh yeah this
is a slightly weird application so
pardon that but you're trying to detect
hair color and from like the celebrity
data set
and turns out that gender is a spurious
correlation because you know in the data
set like most of the
women celebrities have blonde hair
and so if you look at the males of
blonde hair they're actually less than
one percent so i know slightly weird to
call them a minority but oh that's what
wasn't this data set
um
so we see something similar here
where the black curve kind of goes down
uh and then your blue the worst group
error doesn't increase as you increase
the size of the models
so this guy is interested to think about
like you know if we were really trying
to reduce these spurious correlations
and you know this is a dead simple case
where you knew what the correlation is
you knew what each data point was but
still like if you just train the largest
model you can't do well and you kind of
need to rethink like regularization and
how do we train these models
we found that increasing model size
actually increases the voice group error
so now i'll present some explanation for
like why we think this is happening and
what that tells us about how do we
actually fix this problem in practice
so when is it this case that having
large models does worse than having
small models
in the paper we analyzed this you know
the paper here in icml 2020 we analyze
the high dimensional linear setting and
i'll just like have an informal
simplified version here
so we find that we can prove that the
worst group error is high when the
following two conditions hold one is
that the spurious feature which is the
background is somehow easier to learn
for the model than the complex you know
the foreground so like actually looking
at the features of a bird to determine
what the bird is is something much
harder to do than just looking at the
color of the background for example that
pretty much tells you whether it's land
or water
that's the first condition
and then the second condition is that if
there are a lot more majority points
than minority so if you were in a
situation where like you're equally
likely to see a bird in any background
then the model is not going to pick that
up but in reality it is going to be the
case if you just collect data that a lot
more water birds are going to be in
water so this condition holds then we
find this observation
so here's a pictorial description of
what we think is happening here
so let's see this is kind of what the
data look like so you have some land and
you have some water
so a lot of the examples are actually
like water birds in water background
but there is this one example
potentially or like you know minority
example that there is a water bird in a
land background
so now if a model just use a background
to make its prediction it is going to
get this point wrong
and in fact we upgraded this point sorry
so in fact we increase the weight on
this point to precisely prevent
something like this from happening
because this kind of a boundary would
have a high loss and the model is going
to get it wrong and it's going to suffer
a high loss as a result of upgrading
but the problem is when you use a large
model you don't really have a control on
like how the model is going to learn and
one one thing that could happen and we
observe is that the model just kind of
over fits to this particular training
example and does something complex and
learns a boundary that doesn't really
generalize
so because you have a large number of
parameters something like this can
easily happen
and this is kind of what we observe why
the training loss is still zero and so
you do fit this particular point and you
know increasing the weight or not
doesn't matter because already the loss
is zero but the reason the loss is zero
is because the model is doing something
degenerate and doesn't really generalize
so what we find happens is that the
model could fit this particular point
without generalizing to the test set
and they should actually not be that
surprising because you know when we
think about overcome like you know
having a large capacity and traditional
statistics tells us we should be doing
regularization and this could be a
problem
but somehow we don't see this if we just
look at the average error which leads us
to believe that we can't just use the
largest neural network we find and
things are okay
but if you look at this kind of a voice
group at our setting
this is this becomes a real problem
so what we find is that large models can
actually cheat and like overfit to get
these minority points right
and just increasing the weight is not
going to solve this problem because
anyway it already has a low loss and
empirically we find that it is the case
that increasing the weight does not
really solve the problem of spurious
correlations
when you have a large model
um in contrast let's look at what
happens with small models of course if
like models are regularized and they
have a limited capacity they can no
longer do this like cheating
so this is what your data set look like
if the model used the background to make
its prediction it is going to get a high
loss on this it is going to get this
point wrong and we've increased the
weight on this data point so it's going
to like suffer a high rewaited loss so
its objective is going to be high
and it can't do this complicated like
you know boundary around this particular
data point anymore
and so if it has to get a low loss such
that it fits this particular draining
point as well then it has to do
something that doesn't exclusively use
the background
this shows why small models especially
when you re-weight them you can actually
control the kind of boundaries they
learn to say that it gets everything
right and now you don't have the problem
that they're going to just cheat and
overfit and it can actually learn
something more meaningful
what we find is that in this case like
by using small models and regular like
so by regularizing appropriately and
upwarding the minority points
we can actually solve this problem and
get low voice group error
any questions okay
so without kind of theoretical
understanding we try to see there's
anything else that we could do when
using large models or should we just
give up on using large models because
that's what people usually do in
practice though
so we looked at can large models ever
obtain low voice group error
so the two contributing factors from the
theory is that the core feature that is
like the bird features in some sense are
like harder to learn than the background
and there was this group imbalance
so this
is inherent to the data set so we can't
really change like which features are
easy to learn or like what the features
are
but this group imbalance is something
that maybe we could do something and
control via like collecting the data set
carefully
so what so what we were wondering is
whether we can you know reduce this
group imbalance by just removing a lot
of majority points by sub sampling
so what this means is that initially we
had a data set that looks like this
where you have a lot more examples in
your majority and a few in the minority
and in this case like we tried to just
re-weight these points and that didn't
help if you were using large models
so instead what we're saying is like the
theory tells us that like if we didn't
have this group in balance at all then
things would be fine and one way to do
that is to just remove a lot of majority
points and that's what we call sub
sampling
so initially this was a bit strange
because especially in like some of the
datasets that we have this would end up
meaning we removed 90 of the training
points and like removing training data
is just never a thing that people would
ever think of doing because it feels
like data is just always helpful
okay so we'd like this is pretty
counter-intuitive but our theory said
that this should help and so we're like
let's just try and see what happens
and i guess because i'm giving this talk
and it probably works um so what we see
is that so this is the uh figure from
before where you're using the full data
set
so the voice group error like first
decreases and then goes up with large
models
um
we now use a sub sample data set instead
we see that now both the average and the
worst group error go down as we increase
the size of the model and you're back to
kind of the familiar territory where
large models are better and so now like
large models are actually able to get
like you know much better error than
before when they were using the full
data set
so it's kind of surprising that like
removing a lot of data actually helped
solve this problem but you know that's
what we observed
um so we observed something similar on
the celebrity data set as well where
originally
large models were worse and doing badly
but with sub sampling uh large models
are now working better
and that kind of match the performance
of the small models with full data set
and the average error also goes down
which is like kind of what we expect
so we find this interesting observation
that removing majority data
improves the voice group accuracy of
large models
[Music]
those graphs on the right they're on the
same y at x
yeah
then is it is it true that
the best
the sub sampling can get it still looks
a little bit worse
than
uh
the
like the small models if i yeah
re-weighted is that true yeah so i think
there's like we
they're comparable like this is yeah
like on this particular graph it is
lower but like if you do it a little
more carefully like tuned parameters and
like use slightly different models we
were able to bridge the gap so it's not
like i don't think we can conclusively
say that uh re-weighting with small
models is strictly better but like in
some in some cases it is yeah
so could you also hope for other kind of
interventions on the loss function
because
you know the loss maybe it shouldn't be
symmetric or independent of the
background
uh then there could be ways to use the
whole data set but you know bias it
yeah so i think people have tried to do
something like looking at the salient
like some recent work that i've seen
where they try to look at the saliency
maps or like the gradients and say that
the gradient should be like more aligned
with the foreground or something so like
a cement like you kind of segment out
the foreground and then say that the
gradient should be aligned that's i
guess is that the kind of thing that
you're saying so i mean if you have the
protected label of like what the
background is
your loss function could be worse if
it's from a minority group and then you
can also
you know penalize it
so you could still hope for the same
kind of downward slope for the
worst case group accuracy but in a way
that you can still use the full basis
yeah i think one thing that i've seen
people try is to increase the margin
like basically change the exponent and
the losses that you're getting you're
requiring higher margin on the minority
points and the majority point
um i don't
in principle that should help but i
think we don't have a very good way of
like mapping our notion of like what
these networks are doing in terms of
like how to prevent memorization to like
a loss if you had a great way to do that
i think it should work in principle yeah
so the black lines have gotten worse
which you would expect because you have
reduced the data set size right yeah so
that
is a problem so even if you don't reduce
the data set size of that like if you
look here like if you take the best
performing model your like black line is
still higher than here so this seems
like yeah this is one of the other
issues and trying to do any robust
training which is that because you're
forcing like learning the foreground is
actually much harder and so if you have
an image in the test set where you could
have used the background to get it right
but now it's like a complicated burn and
the model is like kind of gonna get it
wrong so it's a bit tricky where like
you kind of want the model to use the
background only if the foreground
doesn't have enough signal but it's not
clear how do we get models to actually
do that
yeah so for this particular setting
where you where is synthetic you can
solve the problem by doing that but i
guess in in practice you'd imagine that
we don't really have a good generative
mechanism but maybe with the progress in
generative models that we have and it
could potentially be possible that we
can do some kind of controllable
generation to help with this problem
okay so let me uh summarize this part
start with this observation that large
models can actually have high words
group error and even if you try to
remove a particular spurious correlation
that exists in a data set you can fail
and the core issue here is that these
features you know um
yeah so yeah basically you're
the type of here like the spurious
features are easier to learn and there's
uh this kind of a group imbalance that
leads to this problem
um
and a theory like a fix based on kind of
this understanding is that we can't
change the features the let's change the
imbalance and kind of sub sampling helps
i would really call this a fix just like
kind of checking that this intuition
makes sense but this is at least one way
in which we can have large models to
have low voice group error
but like you know many if you observe
we're actually sacrificing a lot of data
to use large models there is kind of
this interesting dichotomy that either
we're sacrificing a lot of data or we're
sacrificing a lot of capacity and so you
know clearly there's something better we
can do but we don't have a way to do
that with our kind of current
uh deep learning understanding and
pipeline so far
okay now i'll is there any questions
before i switch to the next part
oh i had a question which is um
i guess like so the formal theorem
uh we saw like a like a high level
version of the theorem but i think that
the re-weighting that you're using is is
a fixed it's just like glass stands
balance
so something like i presume like one
over the class
yeah um
and so then
i'm i'm wondering about
different types of re-weightings that
might depend on the complexity of the
model
um
and
if you guys have thought about something
like that
direct direct direction so instead of
keeping the waiting scheme fixed
uh changing it as the model gets like
more complex
yeah i see
we did not try something with that
yeah i don't have a good intuition
whether something like that would help
because in practice it's not like if you
just take a fixed model its performance
is not that sensitive to like what's the
exact operating factor but like you know
yeah in like a small range so yeah so i
my initial impression that it might not
work very well but like this part it you
could get some kids
so
you know right now i said that like
these networks pick up the like but we
saw one quick example of what's going on
so like what's the broader story of why
networks pick up on certain correlations
that exist in your data set so one of
the disadvantages of just collecting a
lot of data and throwing it at your
model is that there are a lot of
features that are actually predictive
but only some of them are reliable like
for example if you have like only causal
features in your data set that's great
everything's going to be reliable you
can just use it but that's not going to
be the case if you just don't think
about the features and you know give it
a model
strong last minute animations but yeah
so ideally we want to only use reliable
features but this you know was the pro
like it requires information about which
features are reliable
and one thing that we found interesting
was that like this is a very you know
pervasive phenomenon so like on most
data sets we find the neural networks
often use only these spurious
correlations so it's not that they use
some amount of the background but
they're pretty much always exclusively
using the background or like some kind
of texture to make its prediction and so
it's like these are a real problem
because they you know not just that the
models use them but they use them a lot
more than the meaningful signals
so the general kind of story here is
that whenever these spurious patterns
are simpler to learn than reliable ones
which we find is quite a lot in practice
so for example detecting whether a tube
is present or not is of course a much
easier task than like actually seeing if
it's like you know collapsed or not so
whenever you have anything like this
then the model is going to just use the
spurious correlation
so we try to like you know generalize
this a little bit and so we had this
simple and we thought about let's try to
attack the core issue here which is how
do we overcome this kind of a simplicity
bias of neural networks in general
feels like a synthetic data set that we
created that i think was interesting
because you can prove stuff and also see
what's going on
so if you have like a spurious feature
and a robust feature so you see that
both of them give you some information
about the true label which is like blue
or orange
so if you're doing some kind of a max
margin or like trying to do the best
thing that we could with this with this
data set you should be learning
something like this which is you know
using some information about both the
robust and the spurious features and
this kind of keeps these points far from
the boundary
so what we find when we run experiments
is like on on you know all these
different neural network architectures
and across many different learning rates
and everything you basically always
learn something like this where the
model is just going to use the spurious
feature so it's going to learn this
green boundary that separates a data set
even though it could have learned
something that separated your data set
much better because it has the capacity
to express piecewise linear functions
and you could argue that that's not like
it's okay because like this was still
working on your data set so why should
the model be doing anything more
so we like you know made this more noisy
such that the spurious feature is no
longer perfect
and interestingly we see that the neural
network still learns only the green
boundary but basically if you have
points like this just like the land bird
in the water example
uh there is going to be kind of you know
memorized in the sense that they don't
really general like the network is just
going to do something local along this
part instead of actually using that
information to learn the better boundary
so this is kind of interesting it says
that if you just collected a lot of
diverse data on its own that's actually
just insufficient so you could have been
very careful about ensuring that you
capture all the different points in the
tales that could happen
and you just collect a lot of data you
are going to see a bunch of details but
that's just not sufficient because if
they're like not present with high
enough like you know if they're not
present with high enough numbers the
network is still overwhelming
overwhelmingly going to do the simplest
thing
and
so kind of you know with like all this
intuition we try to think about what
what we could do
potentially if we just didn't know
exactly what points to upward
this was the recipe from the previous uh
the first part of the talk which is if
you knew what points to upgrade and then
you kind of regularize your network
carefully you can ensure that you are
not going to memorize these particular
important points and you're forcing the
network to learn something useful
but this was you know like we knew what
point stop wait because we knew kind of
this is a image of a bird in like a
different background and so that's
likely going to be important that the
network should pay attention to
so now we ask can we identify these
points automatically with a little bit
of understanding of like why networks
pay attention to certain points and not
others
okay with this kind of a simple idea
which is that so we observe that so uh
like so there are these important points
in a data set but your model is not
learning from them because we call this
informally memorization
and if you look at the neural network
training this kind of happens later in
training
so um yeah so like it first learns
something linear and then kind of spends
its time fitting those points which
don't match the linear pattern
so that told us that if we could somehow
stop the network when we just learned
the linear thing and then look at which
other points it gets wrong those are
probably going to be the points that the
network would have eventually just done
something degenerate on and so if we
could pick them up and avoid them then
maybe we can get the network to learn
something better from these points
rather than just letting it continue to
train and do something silly
so this was kind of the intuition that
you know because harder to fit points
out the thing that the network misses
out let's identify them by just training
a network for a little bit seeing what
it gets wrong and then operating them
so that led to this kind of two-step
process where we first train a model for
a few iterations so that it doesn't you
know overfit and doesn't fit every
doesn't do these complex patterns
we use that to identify misclassified
points
now these misclassified points are
probably going to be the important
points and so in the second step we
upload them and then we regularize and
like from the kind of understanding from
the first part of the talk they should
actually do something useful because
they're regularizing carefully
and from the you know and because these
points are likely to be important points
since the network gets wrong we kind of
hope that this helps
so this is very very important caviar
that we found is that we didn't know how
to figure out like what how when to stop
training like what is a simple enough
model
so this did require like some kind of
cross validation that leaked some
information about the groups so this is
not a perfect solution but like
empirically does reduce the number of
points on which you need to know what's
going on but this gets at something that
you could try to heuristically do to you
know if you didn't know which points are
important is to like use the network
itself to tell you which points are
important
we're going to try this on these data
sets and it it does it does better than
just standard training but it doesn't
really match what the best you could do
if you had perfect information on which
are the points that you want to use
there's been a lot of other recent works
as well that kind of try to do something
similar where you notice the points that
the network gets wrong and try to get
the model to pay more attention to that
and on this other data set as well it's
kind of similar so it it it works better
and it gets like about
about 80 of the gap is covered by just
this simple idea
this is but not a perfect method in any
means but it kind of gave us some hope
that maybe there is something that you
could do potentially even if you didn't
know everything about what what you want
to remove from your data set
okay
so to summarize
having diverse data on its own is not
sufficient to ensure that networks learn
reliable predictors
and so it seems like an obvious starting
point is like let's assume we have
diverse data but unfortunately that's
itself not sufficient
but maybe there's still something we
could do based on understanding like
what is it that these neural networks
pick up and how do we make sure that
they are using all the diverse data
points in the right way
this requires some regularization of
capacity which is
interestingly contrary to the current
trends i think you know people should be
thinking more carefully about just using
bigger models and throwing a lot of data
because that doesn't actually use all
the data in the right way
and of course like this is not probably
going to be robust to noise because the
neural network could actually be getting
points wrong because they're noisy and
then now if you're kind of operating
them in this way like you know you could
actually make it worse so i think
there's obvious obvious problem like how
do you make sure whether something is
actually an interesting pattern or
something is just noise
and uh want to conclude with sort of
you know like even if we had diverse
data things are bad but like could we
ever get diverse enough trade up
so a lot of research in neural networks
right now is just going along this path
of let's try to get as much data as we
can and so now we've been able to not
use labels and so they have this
so-called self-supervised learning where
you can just give a lot of raw data that
you obtain and so that's a potential
path to get a lot of diversity because
you can literally train on any data that
you can find
but like you know we don't know this
actually contains kind of all these
interventions in some sense that you
should actually hope your model to learn
so that it doesn't learn this kind of
correlation
and even if you have diverse data that's
already like we have to also figure out
how to use the diversity
but like this is obvious question of can
we ever hope to get diverse enough data
i think like the fact that sub sampling
was you know kind of worked pretty well
got me really interested in thinking
more about active data collection and i
keep thinking about is this the way
forward because right now we just like
collect data passively and so we are not
really like we're kind of hoping the
network learns something from the like
the tales but like you're not really you
know collecting them more carefully and
so you know i wonder if active data
collections are way forward and also if
you look at kind of the psychology
experiments and how like we as humans
learn by actually interacting with the
world and like doing experiments on our
own to figure out like what actually
happens when you make certain changes in
the world but a lot of the neural
network training that we have right now
is very different where we just give a
lot of passive data
so as we get more agents to like kind of
interact in the world and think about
active data collection i think that
could be really important and we
shouldn't be going down the path of just
trying to give as much data as we can
find to the models which is kind of what
a lot of research is doing these days
um with that i'll stop and thank
google and open philanthropy for
supporting all this work and my
wonderful collaborators
maybe a quick question
maybe just for those of us who are very
naive about these things what's the
difference between
[Music]
some it sounds to me like increasing
weight on the small set that you care
about is
morally it's not completely technically
equivalent to sub-sampling and i
couldn't understand why these are
different yeah yeah so i guess that's
the that's the point where like the
neural network things matter which is
that if you have a lot of capacity and
you have this really large model
so it can still do degenerate things on
certain data points which like even if
you uploaded the point it doesn't matter
so if you have a large model just
because it has a low loss on a point
doesn't mean it's actually learned the
point so i guess that is why the two
things are different so if we did sub
sampling now
okay so why uh why the model does the
issue in the first place is that if your
90 percent of training data can be
classified by the like a linear boundary
like by the background the model is just
going to learn them and then you have
operators so it will fit those other
points but it will not really generalize
but if you had sub sample
now there's like only 50 percent of the
data point that could actually be
covered by the background so the model
is no longer going to use only the
background and it has to do something
better so that's why sub sampling
matters i think the core point is that
low loss does not really mean anything
when you have a large network because of
the capacity issue do you think that the
optimization like if i'm doing matches
and 99 percent of that there's one extra
data and one person's other
like even if i'm weighting them
differently could that be changing like
the implicit vibes yeah people have
tried a lot of these things yesterday
like you couldn't get any conclusive
results so
it does change things a little bit but
like not yeah it's it's not like a it
doesn't really solve the problem yeah
doesn't help